With your spells. Do you have like, people drink like pigs, blood or something?
Oh God. No. Okay. I don't know. Better.
Talk about some topics are hard to express
either the subjects are inaccessible
or people are uncomfortable discussing.
So we found those subjects in person rented a space in Los Angeles and invited
our audiences, strangers to come and ask them anything.
Hi, my name's Griffin.
I am a professional witch and I'm here today to answer questions on the
topic. Anything anybody would like to ask?
Hi Griffin, I'm Erin two A's biblical name, right?
Kind of a Christian name.
You didn't bring a Pitchfork today. Did you?
Oh, what? Which thing they always would proceed. It just cause you know,
from movies, like.
Female thing,
that was a lot of people think that there is a higher percentage of women,
but not exclusive at all.
And a lot of the people responsible for the revival of witchcraft have been men.
Is being a witch. Like you're.
That's what I do for a living.
I teach witchcraft and I run a witchcraft store and I sent a
big rituals and do all kinds of things.
Or a bad witch. Oh.
Yes I am. I'm not a nice wage, but I'm a good wage.
I don't go out of my way to be nice to people,
but I hope my ethics very close to my heart. I would not do magic.
That would use SERP. The Liberty of freedom of others.
I feel the way witches are being portrayed.
Do like social media or like in movies?
Well, I think it would be portrayed actually in a fun way.
It's it's not very realistic. I don't fly on Brahms and uh,
people really don't understand witchcraft. They see witchcraft from Hollywood.
They see witchcraft through the filter of history, but they don't,
it's very difficult to understand what we're about from the outside.
I've come to accept that. I can't really explain it to people and that's okay.
Like Catholic or Muslim or Buddhist. Could you practice kind of the,
which style even though you're not maybe like a Wiccan,
like how does that work out? Religious ones?
You can be a witch and you can be a Christian.
You can be a witch and you can be an atheist. Um,
but people who practice old time,
witchcraft very often have the ability to perceive energy and
spirits and manipulate change.
So that's helpful for when communicating with nature,
different kinds of spirits in the land or doing healing work, uh,
being able to work with crystals and stones.
How did you fall into being a wedge? Like,
did you feel like you had a gift or something or did you just.
My mother, her mother before her, um, had what they call the gifts.
She was in her seventies and decided that it was time to cross over.
So she drowned herself in a bucket of water. Oh.
Which is not an easy thing to do, but she was ready.
It was because she was aware of the spirit realm. And she said, you know,
I've had a really long life and I'm done,
I'm ready to cross over a year after she crossed I was born and my
grandmother looked at me and basically said, Oh,
you've received the gifts from her mother.
Have you ever cast a spell on yourself before? And would you recommend it?
Yeah, actually I know it sounds kind of weird.
People come in wanting you to cast spells on other people.
I want that boyfriend or I want that girlfriend and I want you to make them love
me and this, like, no, I'm not going to do that. If you want to be loved,
then you need to start finding a way to love yourself.
People see you differently when you see yourself differently.
So a lot of spoke crafting is actually done on oneself. Strangely enough,
love yourself, love yourself.
It's going to be like a dumb question, but like,
have you ever like experienced like sort of like a witch fight?
Oh my God, you're going in there. All right. Um, yeah, you know,
I'd love to say that that, which is,
are all wonderfully enlightened and tolerant and loving,
but actually there's a hell of a lot of which was go on where, Oh,
so-and-so said this about you and sciences and that's just normal,
like high school drama. But with witches,
it gets also into where they start throwing spells and uh,
and trying to mess with your life. And the silly thing is,
is if you do witchcraft against another person,
then whatever you do against them opens the door that they can do the same thing
back at you or other people can do that kind of magic on you because once the
door is opened in, in what you endorse in your reality,
then that becomes something that is always going to be a power in your,
in your world.
GK exists in a sense of like what we see in movies or anything,
or is it more a spirituality type thing?
You know, uh, both, maybe 90% of my practice.
It is about how to see a bigger universe and to live in a bigger
spiritual based world.
But then there's 10% of the practice where magic becomes very real.
When you see things happen that physically shouldn't be possible,
but it's not something that you are able to conjure up on a daily basis.
It's not like a waste where you wiggle your nose and the housework started,
or the dishes take care of themselves. What do you think of Christianity?
I like Christianity in terms of Christ. And in terms of the, uh,
the scripture, what I'm not a big fan of is churchianity,
I don't like the way in which priesthood in all religions and all mainstream
religions, um, mediate the scriptures, um,
because it seems to be geared towards fundamentalism, um, bigotry.
Uh closed-mindedness.
Have you faced any like negativity to you being so open? What, well.
Yeah, I mean, when I first started, um, I wouldn't admit it to anybody. I mean,
people would think I was nuts and in America,
even where there's still a degree of persecution, so we keep,
we keep kind of quiet about who we are and what we're doing.
What's something about like being a witch that most people don't really know.
They're just like regular people. Um,
I know which is who are doctors and surgeons and lawyers and
in every area of the world, there are people who you don't know,
which is so the fact that, you know,
we come in all in all colors in all flavors fact that we actually are decent
people. I want people to realize that we hold value in the world,
that we have a place and that we aren't scary people.
We're actually kind of cool with it.
If you could recollect, what is your greatest or fondest journey?
Um, well,
there's a number of workings that I've done over the years with other people
where we have been out in nature. And, uh,
and we have seen things that have basically taken our
understanding of reality and shredded it,
where we have seen spirits of people become manifest,
where we've watched fire take foam and reach out like a hand and touch
people.
The thing that's the most important to me and the thing that I get the biggest
reward from actually is working with people today and,
and seeing the light go on in their eyes when they start to realize that
that there's more to the world and that it can be an adventure.
And I feel like I've made a difference and that really makes me feel good. Well,
thanks guys for watching.
I hopefully you learned a thing or two about witchcraft and
continue to seek. If you have interests, seek out your metaphysical stores.
And please remember to comment below what you thought of the episode,
consider liking and subscribing as well. And we will see you next time.
Right?